okay you applauded way too long for that
here's how the survey works we asked
three celebrities to complete a phrase
our first phrase was the sequel I'm most
looking forward to is Reese Witherspoon
said Toy Story for Seth Green said The
Incredibles to Donald Trump said World
War three that was his yeah can't
believe he answered me but he did yeah
people don't recognize me without slash
said a top hat and guitar Tom Selleck
said my mustache
Steve Benin said Slave Leia chained to
my side when I saw a Wonder Woman in the
theater I was Lily Collins said blown
away Anna Kendrick said inspired Snoop
Dogg said super high what happened
exactly sure mr. good movie it's good
the only thing that can really hurt me
is Dwayne Johnson said a sucker punch
Christina Aguilera said a bad review
Jeff sessions said a strong wind when my
ears are at full mast
that problem there now a fun thing to do
on weekends is Owen Wilson said fly a
kite at the beach Amanda Seyfried said
play softball Ron Perlman's said
frighten zoo animals how do you like
that orangutan the most important word
in the English language is Jennifer
Aniston said love Ryan Reynolds said
truth Melania Trump said help a show I
have never seen but would probably love
is Elon Musk said mr. robot David Lynch
said Westworld chris christie said the
leftovers
I'm really sorry that one just snuck
through uh in my opinion Jesus Christ
was Patricia Heaton said the Son of God
Gary Oldman said a great philosopher
Larry King said a lousy roommate
and finally Harry Potter's final battle
with Lord Voldemort was Anthony Anderson
set a classic story of good versus evil
Patton Oswalt said a terrifying showdown
between light and dark Donald Trump said
a complicated situation with many sides
you
you